Olha só, você sabia que a maioria das
pessoas foge da colunoscopia por medo?
Pois é, mas agora isso pode mudar
completamente, porque acabou de sa um
estudo mostrando que um simples exame de
fees consegue detectar até 90% dos casos
de câncer intestino. Isso mesmo, 90%. E
olha que interessante, eles usam
inteligência artificial para analisar as
bactérias do seu intestino. Porque veja
bem, quando tem um tumor se formando
ali, toda a microbiota muda, fica
desequilibrada de um jeito bem
específico. E por que isso é
revolucionário? Primeiro porque a
coloscopia é invasiva, né? Precisa de
preparo, sedação, pessoal tem medo,
resultado, muita gente simplesmente não
faz. E o câncer de intestino, que é
super tratável quando pego no início,
acaba sendo descoberto tarde mais. Com
esse teste novo, você coleta em casa,
manda pro laboratório e aí faz toda a
análise. Simples assim. E o melhor, a
precisão é praticamente a mesma da
colonoscopia tradicional. Imagina
quantas vidas isso pode salvar, né?
Yeah.